[Music]
here is Grand Rapids Michigan a town
becoming widely known to Dennis a
municipal authority mint tooth decay the
children in Grand Rapids have less tooth
decay and they did six years ago as much
as 65% less Grand Rapids fight against
tooth decay started in January 1945 when
fluoride was added to the water supply
this was done as part of a study to
determine the effect of fluoridation on
tooth decay participating in the study
are city officials dentists Michigan
State Department of Health University of
Michigan and the US Public Health
Service after six years of fluoridation
the study shows that the six-year-old
children who drank the water from birth
had 65 percent less tooth decay the
seven-year olds forty five percent less
and so on even the sixteen year olds who
started drinking the water when they
were ten years old
received some benefits 16% less tooth
decay sixteen years after fluoridation
all children 16 years old and under will
have 65% less tooth decay studies in
Newburgh New York Sheboygan Wisconsin
Marshall Texas Lewiston Idaho Brantford
Ontario and other cities shows
substantially the same results as those
obtained at Grand Rapids other studies
show the benefits of fluoridation will
last throughout life
most of the many communities now
fluoridating add sodium silica fluoride
or sodium chloride to their water
another compound also used is
hydrofluoric acid
all three are effective and cheap in a
town of 5,000 population the daily
amount of the fluoride compound and its
cost is sodium silica fluoride seven
pounds cost forty-nine cents
sodium fluoride ten Khan's
cost one dollar twenty cents
hydrofluoric acid about two gallons one
dollar 61 cents in selecting one of the
three compounds the size of the town and
its water plant facilities are
considered three types of feeders are
used to add fluoride compounds one is
the solution feeder used in towns up to
about twenty thousand population another
type is the volumetric feeder a dry
feeder for towns or from 1,000 to
120,000 the third type is the
gravimetric feeder for feeding the dry
compound in cities of more than 120,000
all three feeders the solution feeder
the volumetric feeder and the
gravimetric are equipped with automatic
controls and have long been used for
adding chemicals to city water supplies
generally the fluoride content of the
water is determined by the color metric
test in this test a color indicator is
added to water samples the color of the
samples is then matched with the color
of standards containing known amounts of
fluoride
dentists in many cities are helping to
bring the benefits of fluoridation to
children now our children can have
dental health through fluoridated water
they can drink away
tomorrow's tooth decay have more
attractive teeth the cost is about 10
cents a year per person
fluoridation is endorsed by the American
Dental Association state and territorial
dental health directors American
Association of public health dentist
Public Health Service Federal Security
Agency state and territorial health
officer American Public Health
Association and the American Medical
Association
you